it's beginning to not look a lot like
Christmas everywhere you go
Trump's elected as president science has
projected natural disaster sunken cities
and the snow is not beginning to look a
lot like Christmas extreme weathers is
store but the most normal sight to see
is the climate refugee knocking on your
door
Miami is Friday Bangladesh has got a new
york in december supposed an associate
call this unleashed atmosphere has
decreased merchant presence can now is
on travel and hurricanes have made it so
school never starts again wait I don't
understand Celsius only Fahrenheit fake
Christmas tree fake Christmas tree
you aren't environmentally friendly your
pine is made of PVC too many carcinogens
for me you might have thought I'm saving
trees but carbon emissions are three
times higher than
cut down tree so get a real one that
immediately guys did you ever know that
reindeer have capillaries in they're not
using a thermal camera you would even
see it glow literally all of the other
reindeer are female in this son ring to
shed their antlers in winter so the
names in the song are wrong the most
important question of our time is do you
see what I see us no seriously
is your red the same red as my red or
the green or blue do you see what I see
this qualia is driving me insane cuz
perception happens in the brain
our experiences even the same
holy night you stop everything shining
your gravity is too strong to let us see
such compact mass deforming space and
timing till you appear at the
singularity
your homes the force will nearly kill
you yourself torn up stretched out a
plasmic death
oh why did you go back hey guys thank
you so much for watching hope you
enjoyed the video we had a ton of fun
making it was John who has been a huge
inspiration for us by long time make
sure you subscribe to this channel
because his videos are amazing you
literally like we sing them all the time
like you were humming in a lot of
districts like those things over there
we'll put links in the description to
check them out otherwise we hope you
enjoyed this and we'll see you later yes